If you want to make sure that your food is safe and fresh and good for you,...
...I think the number one awesome thing you can do is go to your local farmer's market.
I just think that's key.
I think it's one of the things that really can make a huge impact on helping the world right now.
But I get it's difficult too because organic food costs more.
When you go to your farmer's market, you're actually getting it directly from the farm.
You don't have those costs that are put on that are at a supermarket.
It's something that you should really look out for.
Don't just go for the organic apple you see because it could be grown in New Zealand.
And does it really make sense to buy an organic apple from New Zealand?
I don't think so.